during a preview for Flintlock the siege
of dawn we saw a 15-minute gameplay
walkthrough of the upcoming open world
action RPG it's looking like developer
a44 games is building upon its debut
title Ashen to bring an even heavier
Focus to fast-paced combat while still
supporting its style of a Cooperative
Focus souls-like experience here are 9
things we learned about Flintlock during
the preview
oh
mechanically flintlock's combat sort of
looks like how you fight insecuro
Shadows die twice with an armor system
that works in a similar manner to
sekiro's posture in Flintlock enemies
have two different meters that you have
to worry about while in combat the red
bar is an enemy's Health while the
yellow bar above that is their armor the
yellow bar fills as you damage an
enemy's armor while the Red Bar empties
as you damage the enemies themselves
attacks deal damage while both attacks
and parries chip away at an enemy's
armor when the armor bar is filled
protagonist nor is able to land a
devastating execution attack against her
foe in most cases against normal enemies
it looks like these executions killer
targets outright however stronger
enemies and bosses can seemingly
withstand multiple versions of these
attacks they're still worth doing though
because when it comes to these more
powerful targets nor can use this
execution attack to rip away an enemy's
literal armor like a shield or
breastplate that makes them more
vulnerable to her attacks in Flintlock
an enemy's armor meter begins to deplete
if you back off encouraging you to be
aggressive in combat and rely on parries
and Dodges instead of blocks
in combat you can control Nora's
companion Inky to stun enemies and stop
their armor meter from depleting but it
looks like you can only do this to one
enemy at a time nor has armor too
powerful attacks like unblockable
attacks that are symbolized by Red Aura
can cut into that armor and damage it
once it's broken nor takes increased
damage from enemy attacks thankfully
there's a way to replenish Nora's armor
which leads us into our next Point how
Anor finishes off a foe will determine
what sort of resources she gets for the
kill both your armor and bullets are
limited and you'll need to kill enemies
to replenish your stores in both
finishing off an enemy with Nora's ax
replenishes her bullets while executing
them with a firearm fixes her armor in
order to remain at full strength you'll
have to mix up your combat style and
finish off groups of enemies with both
your blade and your bullets
what looks like Nora is going to hold on
to her trusty ax for most of the game
she can unlock and use a variety of
firearms beyond the pistol she starts
with and especially useful looking one
is the flintlock rifle which allows Nora
to freely aim and snipe targets from
further away it seems to incorporate a
Gears of War style timing mechanic on
the reload as well we also saw that Nora
can unlock a hand mortar which allows
her to deal a ton of damage in an area
of effect explosion nor can also use
handfuls of gunpowder while exploring or
fighting this allows her to double jump
in the air and extend the distance of
her Dodge like Ashen Flintlock is a
souls-like you've got your bonfire
resting points health potions rhythmic
combat and several other similarities to
from software's souls-borne games
however in designing flintlock's combat
a44 also took a lot of inspiration from
2018's God of War Nora's companion Inky
is basically her atreus you control
enki's actions directing him to stun or
distract enemies but buff noor's attacks
or help Noor move throughout the world
enki also speaks to Noor even warning
her of coming attacks powerful enemies
here even for you
the best attitude a44 art director
Robert Bruce describes noran enki's Bond
as a strong companionship or buddy cop
situation saying that the two have the
same goal even if it is for different
reasons and similar to Kratos and atreus
and God of War the evolving dynamic
between nor and enki is at the heart of
flintlock's narrative Flintlock does not
build on ashen's story though it does
expand on its emphasis in terms of
repopulating a fantasy world as you push
further into flintlock's world and
defeat the enemies that have occupied
towns and buildings it will allow life
to return to these areas similar to the
folks who come to reside in vagrant's
rest in Ashen it looks like most of the
NPCs who reinhabit these areas don't do
much Beyond filling the space with life
that doesn't want to viciously kill you
the especially helpful characters seem
to be a part of your Caravan flintlock's
main Hub area that moves throughout your
journey a44 created a new language for
Flintlock which is spoken by the gods
that Noor is hunting the the studio
worked with linguists to ensure a
consistency across the entire language
so if decoding real world foreign
tongues or fictional video game
languages is your thing you may be able
to figure out what the gods are yelling
at nor as she's shooting them in the
face
Flintlock will be an open world game but
the world will be divided into three
separate zones a44 looked to its home
country of New Zealand for inspiration
when constructing the geography
architecture plants and creatures of
these three zones though each one will
possess its own unique style the gods
that nor is hunting and form the world
around them so you can in turn look to
how each of the three zones are built to
get hints as to what gods may make their
home there for example the nightly god
of knowledge resides in a tower within
Sybil which is a port city Sybil is
built on an ancient archive and is the
center of learning in the world of
Flintlock operating as a hub of trade
knowledge and commerce Flintlock may be
an open world that will encourage you to
explore in multiple directions but you
won't have a mount to speed that along
nor will be forced to walk for most of
her Adventure though there will be
select narrative moments where she takes
Alternative forms of Transport you can
unlock new navigational abilities though
for example using enki nor can teleport
to certain locations marked by glowing
symbols allowing her to bypass parts of
the world in the demo we saw one of
these glowing symbols appeared in a
place that allowed Noor to teleport over
a building and passed an area she'd
completed before allowing her to more
quickly return to a tough enemy
encounter without going through a
gauntlet of foes first Flintlock has
coffee shops though they aren't manned
by the sort of Baristas you're used to
the owners of these shops are these
multi-armed creatures that actually hold
up their own face with one pair of arms
while they use sign language with their
other arms to communicate with you and
the other patrons you can visit coffee
shops to rest up and hear gossip that
will lead you into new quests you can
also use these shops to fast travel
allowing you to return to previously
visited zones more quickly and those
were our major takeaways from the
preview for more on Flintlock be sure to
check out Gamespot for a written preview
of the game
[Music]